[Music]
you look fantastic oh thanks you really
do you look stunning thank you and
congratulations you uh recently had your
third child a boy i did yeah
have you losing your mind uh i have two
children and my wife at the very thought
of a third was like this is what all i
can handle i i okay let me tell you
something she was right
um
i definitely
you know we we wanted a third
we had a third i wouldn't trade him for
anything but you know how two feels like
six
three just put me right over the edge
like just right i was going up to anyone
people on the street and saying will you
come work at my house will you please
come and just help me just take a child
just make do something okay that's bad
you've got to stop doing that yeah you
should ask them a couple of questions
yeah i can't wait till our third child
looks up this footage and sees that you
think of him as a horrible mistake
[Music]
it'll be on youtube yeah don't worry you
know what my mom's going to take a
ception shoe you said when you have
three it might as well be six my mom had
six she would not agree she would say
six is i understand that but anyway one
day i kind of looked around i was like
what are you all doing here i'm fine
goodbye go away i ran into you uh not
too long ago you and and your husband
ben we were uh
i forget we were down in santa monica i
ran into you at some event and he had
this crazy beer yes he did that he grew
for the movie argo i think for a while
yeah and and he he had that beard for a
while and he's looking mad there um
did your i had a beard a while ago and
my kids flipped out they hated it it
scared them he they hated it just
because it's scratchy
um
i i liked it it was i liked it but then
the weird thing is when it all goes and
you feel like there's a different person
in your house and you feel like oh back
up i don't know exactly who you are it
could have been one of the 70 people you
hired at the galaxy exactly i might have
tried to hire him i might have run into
him in the starbucks and i'll come up so
you'd be okay with him growing it back
if he grew it back
whatever
sure you know what i mean yeah whatever
eye patch beard pirate hat you don't
care i don't care
you take them how you get them now uh
this is interesting for a family dynamic
not many people can relate to this but
you have a film butter that's going to
be out the same time as your husband's
film argo
which film do you tell the audience to
go see if they can only see one
that's a tough one yeah
um well butter comes out the week before
argo so definitely go see butter first
but then definitely go see argo
so you're saying see both of them
multiple times i think that's what you
said butter it took my producing partner
and me four and a half years to get
buttermaid and out and we love it and
we're so proud of it and it's really fun
and funny and you're gonna love it argo
is one of the best movies of the year i
mean i could sit right here and we could
do this whole interview about argo is
fantastic um
butters is too
that's very impressive what you just did
you just plugged two movies
simultaneously i want to get my money's
worth
i'm here for a short time and go any
real estate you want to sell
exactly